[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah well
yeah ming nah yeah tim congratulations
on this you guys
tim for you
first you've been a part of the star
wars family for
what 20 years now right how does it feel
for you to be
fronting this
this show with this character
unbelievable the year 2000 i played
jango fett and attack of the clones and
there's no
even thought of being involved in
something in the future but for this to
come about and how it came about so uh
john favreau dave filoni uh robert
rodriguez and to be part of that family
i'm still pitching myself and um still
really in a way can't believe it i
wanted to do a good job when i entered
the mandalorian so it paid off i'm boba
fett
me now i paid off for you how does it
feel for you to be joining the star wars
universe in such a prominent role now
well it's kind of um fantastical because
fennec was never in any of the previous
star wars projects and so she's a a
fresh character and i feel like i i was
able to create and and give birth to
this character being such a huge star
wars fan
i know
how um this fandom has an incredibly
powerful strong opinion and passion
for anything star wars so um the
acceptance and love that fennec shant
has received is tremendous i'm i'm i'm
just like blown away by it and now
you know to be resurrected and partnered
up with the legendary boba fett and
having our own series is like what is
happening what is going on i was just so
lucky that uh i played jango fett and
boba fett was the clone son so he had to
look like django so that's right i'm
lucky i'm the luckiest guy right and
boba saves fedex which is great but i'd
like to say because you know john and
dave wanted to bring me back
so they're like who could we bring back
to say fennick oh boba fett
when we start this this series in
particular i i like being your your
reference to uh
you know birthing this character because
this feels like a rebirth for boba fett
yes this isn't the boba fett that we
know in the movies this is
him at a different point in his life
obviously explain his head space now yes
well he's uh going through exactly what
you said that rebirth is uh he's
stripping away the layers we're finding
a little bit more about the uh what
makes him ticks uh again they both have
near-death experiences almost being
buried in the sand alive
again getting to know a new tribe and
being accepted into a kind of family
environment with the tuscan raiders and
he's changing his ways and he's a little
bit more open obviously he needs
some backup in terms of uh
uh mingnas character so uh
yeah so i think the series allows us to
explore though that void that that we
that we knew little of because uh he
wasn't seen that much in those earlier
sagas so um
so now yes it's all about just revealing
the real bobber
and uh he wants to lead this
organization and
and this arena with respect so uh we'll
see how he goes about that in the next
section we'll see if it works yeah and a
lot of humor on the line because he has
to
reevaluate sometimes he's used to doing
things a certain way but now a little
bit more diplomacy might come in handy
here and then so obviously we have this
rapport going between the two characters
and and that brings another level again
but also it's it's an area that we're
not 100 familiar with at all and you
know it's sort of like
learning to walk again a little bit
trying to figure out what will work and
what won't work and old habits die hard
um
and
i think fennick still believes that
the quicker way is with fear not with
respect
if you had spoken such insolence to
jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
please
speak freely
speaking of fear we have we see you know
in episode two we have the hutt's return
there's now this uh this black wookie
chrysanthemum baby people are saying um
wasn't he magnificent i mean
this is like chekhov's wookie there's no
way you guys aren't gonna throw down
with it with him well you have to wait
and see what are these action scenes
like i mean because it's the action in
the show is fantastic
i imagine it's a lot of fun but i also
imagine at this point in your life
there's a there's a little piece of you
that feels a little bit like boba in
that first episode it's like
get me back to the healing pod that was
a lot of work i would like to sit down
for a moment
i think that's a we're going to put that
on a t-shirt
get me to the
it back a very physical shoot we both
had to prepare physically uh we did a
lot of the the movement a lot of it
ourselves because so they could see who
it was so
but that kind of helps we enjoy that
kind of stuff keeps us fit too but uh by
six o'clock in the afternoon and you're
still out there on the sand swinging
that stick around oh you start getting a
few it's like a few aches and pains but
uh
[Music]
you